a high-rise is defined by the mix of
glass metal and stone that is the face
it shows to the world
[Music]
Evos exterior began with its architects
this is just much more appropriate lead
design architect Robert Thompson wanted
a building that took full advantage of
the California signing this is gonna be
pretty incredible to have this whole
taut glass facade and then have the
rhythm of these elements marching their
way down
you know the facade I think this is
gonna really create a pretty cool
pattern you know on the building he
chose more to ceiling windows combined
with sleek aluminum panels the best way
to achieve this look was to use a
curtain wall a curtain wall is a system
of prefabricated non-structural panels
that hang on the building like a curtain
we have I think more flexibility in
terms of creating a much tighter more
elegant more sophisticated type of skin
in this process and it's far more
waterproof another major advantage to
using a curtain wall is that it can be
assembled off-site in a controlled
environment
for the curtainwall contractor benson
industries this was the best way to
tackle Evo's many design challenges
condominiums are very very complicated
from a design standpoint because they
don't have a lot of balconies but a lot
of doors which are very difficult to
seal against air and water the design
specs require the panels to resist rain
driven by 75 mile-per-hour winds rubber
gaskets and silicone seals provide a
first layer of protection any water that
gets past them will be drained away by
gutters built into the aluminum frame
the panels also need to stay put during
high winds and earthquakes in 1972 the
glass panels and a Boston skyscraper
began to mysteriously pop out crashing
into the street below there were
hundreds of pieces of glass fell out of
the building essentially what had to
happen is they had to put up sidewalk
barricades go in and replace all of the
of the failed product with plywood and
then try to find out what was wrong
though the official cause was never
released
some believe that wind blowing across
the glass created a suction effect
pulling the panel's
out of their frames
to prevent this from happening on Evo
the glass is held in place using
structural caulking unlike metal
fasteners silicone can stretch to absorb
forces from wind heat even an earthquake
it's the only thing holding the glass in
place